e
good morning everyone uh being uh 10:02
I'd like to open the meeting
um and I would ask uh representative
Merchant if he would lead us in the
yes thank you and I just want to remind
everyone what our mission is we are a
bipartisan committee that is tasked with
investigating and evaluating the state's
response to the covid-19 pandemic the
committee will function in a
science-based fact finding
review specifically acquiring
comprehensive accurate data and all
related information pertaining there to
areas of particular Focus will include
the administration of federal guidance
acceptance of federal funds and
implementation of the emergency use
authorization vaccination efforts a
report will be issued out Ling the
committee's findings and the impact on
New Hampshire and this morning I would
truly like to uh thank director buckton
um who after a lot of uh cancellations
uh is here and thank you director
buckton for being here we are so gra uh
I am so grateful that you were able to
make our
meeting so the floor is is yours good
morning and uh thank you for the
opportunity to meet with you this
morning
um going to start with just a couple of
things uh
so um my name is Rob buckon I'm the have
the privilege of being the director of
Homeland Security and Emergency
Management for the State of New
Hampshire um I was appointed and
confirmed by the governor and Council in
September of
2022 that date's important for you to
recognize as we sit down and have our
conversation this morning um prior to my
role as the Director of Homeland
Security emergency management I enjoyed
a 30-year career in the en hampsh of
fire service with the last nine and a
half years serving as the fire chief
Emergency Management director and public
health officer for the town of Hudson
New Hampshire uh up until my time that I
came to work for the state so my my view
today is uh um offering you as more or
less as a customer based on the fact
that I was not part of the Command Staff
prior my arrival obviously um and I
think it's important to recognize that
75% of the agency at HSM has less than
three years with the agency so there has
been quite a turnover in that group uh
since we started okay uh and since
covid-19 set in in March of 2020 so I I
think that's important it's my
understanding that we're here to discuss
uh unified command is really the role is
the piece that I was asked to talk about
today and that was uh through the chair
and and working with DHHS so um I'm
really more of a discussion person so
I'm not really here to offer you
testimony I'll start some with some
definition type stuff but please this is
your group I'm here to offer you some
input and and I can probably have a
unique perspective based on the fact of
where I was a customer going through
this whole process so um unified command
is really the opportunity for The
Incident Commander uh the overall
authority figure over an incident to
bring together a group of
stakeholders uh to help make decisions
okay uh in this case uh through the
covid-19 pandemic you had a team of
folks that were supporting the governor
of the state of New Hampshire that was
made up of the Department of Health and
Human Services the uh division of um
Homeland Security emergency management
and then National Guard were really the
three big legs uh that came to that
stool to support the governor as we made
decisions as to how that response was
going to move forward this is a uh
common practice that is utilized across
the country uh on large scale incidents
uh and is something that we utilize day
in and day out um so from an incident
management perspective uh it was very
key for command and control perspective
to utilize that to to make sure we were
making you know good decisions and and
how we were going to deal with really
what was ended up being an unprecedented
event not only for New Hampshire but for
the country uh and move forward from
there so that is the definition I guess
I am more uh open to asking you what you
would like to discuss or if you have
anything specific you would like me to
key in on in regards to how that
operates or how that work you know how
that works and how that affected the
overall operation and I can try to scope
that a little
bit does anyone have any specific
questions represent Belcher thank you
madam chair and thank you so much for
being here to provide this information
to us um just just to start out with can
could you give us just a sort of you
know 10,000 foot
view what because of course there were
there were so many facets of covid-19
response from so many different angles
can you just kind of highlight
what um what parts of that were under
the you know the broad sort of
jurisdiction or implementation of uh
Department of Homeland
Security under the Department of
Homeland Security or under underneath
the unified
command um let's look I think first at
Department of Homeland Security sure
thank you so under um RSA 21p the
director of Homeland Security and
Emergency Management is charged with the
over overall planning and implementation
of Emergency Response plans for uh the
state of New Hampshire and we are
charged with um making sure that those
plans meet not only the needs of the
State of New Hampshire but we're also
implementing practice good best practice
from the federal government from um FEMA
um so our plan is developed and reviewed
every five years uh and we the seoc
pulls together the state Emergency
Operations plan uh and that encompasses
several different things everything from
energy to Sheltering uh and we have at
our our fingertips the ability to bring
in Partners State Partners to help
support the local communities in the
state of New Hampshire every disaster
starts locally correct right so uh if
you think about our form of government
that means that we
have 234 communities that come directly
to uh hscm okay there's no in between
there's no County uh county level um
support it comes directly to the state
so the seoc as we call it or an
Emergency Operations Center over on
Smoky Bear Boulevard that's where that
takes place and so all of the requests
come in we actually have a unit that
gets stood up the local liais online a a
local community can go on weboc which is
the program that we utilize put in a
request and that comes in and it gets
filtered into the plan for the next
operational period and get that request
gets answered sometimes they take five
minutes sometimes they may take a couple
hours sometimes in the covid-19 world
I'm sure there were some that took over
a day right so that's how the process
works it starts locally the information
comes in and we are support in nature
right because every every uh Community
is really providing those services to
citizens followup
thank you madam chair and and thank you
for that I'd like to drill a little
deeper into one of the things you
mentioned which is that
um the New Hampshire Department of
Security seems to fall as far as their
their protocols and how they go about
things under the um a set of guidelines
best best practices I believe you said
promulgated by FEMA can you just give us
an idea of whether you might say some
most or all of the best practices
adopted by DHS uh originate with the
federal
government so FEMA is a at the federal
level big picture- wise FEMA rolls up
underneath the Department of Homeland
Security at the federal level and they
have several different agencies
underneath them one which is FEMA and we
are broken down into 10 regions and you
know we're in the New England region
obviously and uh we actually our
planning process we receive support from
the federal government right so for the
Stafford act which really lays out how
we recover uh was built on um hurricane
response right so that's the originality
of how uh you know recovery process was
put in place through the Stafford Act
was how to deal with hurricanes uh over
that time that is certainly uh expanded
as we've seen tornado response
earthquakes and all those things kick up
um but the framework from an incident
management standpoint at after 9911
really highlighted the fact that we
needed a national framework for how
we're going to address incidents and
that is the uh National Incident
Management System uh and that breaks
down how we look at incident command
unified command how the branches are set
up so we can address the needs of the
public and provide them with the best
service whether it's in the response
mode or the recovery mode we basically
take it from the beginning of the
representative Merchant thank you madam
chair and thank you director buckon for
being here I'd like to go back up to
probably around 30,000
ft help me understand there's the issue
of what needs to be done versus how to
do it and I'm trying to drill down into
the separation of those two fundamental
principles is the Department of Homeland
Security setting policy or you basically
implementing the policy that was
set so can we just one clarification on
my end when we talk about the Department
of Homeland Security you're talking
federally and not the state level at the
state level so basically I'm trying to
get you is that there needs to be a
decision what has to be done which is
more of the policy side but there also
has to be support to ensure that that
decision is carried out so at the state
level is the role of the State homel
security and unified command to
basically execute the orders yeah
basically you're not enrolled to make
and decide the what orders have to be
done it's more to be sure that the order
wherever it came from is executed it's a
great question so the unified command
group and bringing those uh subject
matter experts so whether it's
um trying to give you a simple example
here but the subject matter experts are
in the room who provide input to the
decision maker meaning The Incident
Commander who sets policy and then gives
it back to the operational group to
follow up so I want to follow up on the
question about the instant um command um
making that decision are you making a
policy decision or making an operational
decision about how to carry out the
policy can you clarify that for me
please yeah it's
a we're making an operational decision
at the start
yep represent
Vil thank you very much for being here
we've uh eag I think we can say we've
eagerly awaited uh having you here to
have this
conversation well I mean we're already
learning I mean I hadn't looked at RSA
21p so that's good to know that's there
and we can look at it um I've just just
got a few just to learn so are there a
whole set of rules then that are
associated with the statute and and your
implementation Powers Yeah so that's
that's a great question and the answer
to that is no uh so basically Ally the
reality is we are empowered to
implement Implement process and best
practice so we follow under the uh
National framework and Nims so that is
where that's pulled together and we pull
the planning piece together uh but if
you were looking to go to the rule set
for the State of New Hampshire it says
incident command means this and
operationally periods are defined as
this every incident brings its own
challenges so whether it's like uh the
storm that we had in at the beginning of
April where we had 182,000 people
without power that is a pretty much a
very uh small uh activation for us
because we're bringing in very few
stakeholders when you get to the
covid-19 response you're really talking
about a
humongous uh unprecedented event that
may made us look at Logistics how we're
going to deliver supplies how we're
going to look at testing how we're going
to look at vaccin ation efforts how
we're going to look at getting
information out to the public health
officials and the local emergency
management directors so the communities
can make decisions at their level in
regards to uh what they were going to do
with their their practices and how they
were going to approach us at the Town
level okay um and go from there so so
just can I just ask a couple followups
sure okay I mean it won't because we've
got a so um so on a very like surface
level you said that you folks have an
yep what was the when was the last time
that plan had been updated when covid
hit number one and number two did the
plan
include pandemic type
responses because I think what you said
is most of what these plans are concept
calized on is a a a
natural act then it had to be expanded
to like 911 but anyway I we're trying as
we get to the preparedness
issue yep so um it's a two-part answer
uh a two two questions yeah so so the
fir first part
is the uh last update to the plan was
done in 2019 so if you add the five year
window we're actually starting right now
the review for the state Emergency
Operations plan to update that so it's
new and fresh at the end of 24 going
into 25 okay so that's the first answer
so it had been updated just prior to uh
the uh covid-19 pandemic um if you go
and you look at 21p it will talk about
the uh coordinating of efforts with
public health so we are we partner with
public health and
DHHS almost on a daily basis if we have
an incident there in the EOC very
frequently because we're talking about
Sheltering practices how to set up
Regional shelters how do we get out if
we need to get food out or if a
community needs to get water in how how
are we managing that and managing the
Red Cross and some of our
nonprofits so when you look at the um
the second part of the question
regarding public health and is that plan
ready to
be um Nimble enough to bring the
response in that's exactly what it's set
up to do so the national Incident
Management System is set up to work with
the different stakeholders to adjust its
framework to be able to support them now
on the public health side of of and I'm
speaking for my public health days here
for a second as the public health
official in Hudson we we had worked on
uh point of distribution plans and um
you know bird flu type type stuff prior
to this so there were practices and
drills that had been done prior to the
covid-19 response at a at a smaller
scale right when you start talking about
the covid-19 response and you start
looking at that scale uh it was
something we hadn't seen but that
doesn't mean the framework wasn't there
to be nimble to to adjust and bring that
forward to be able to support the
communities going and then I'll stop so
um well because I had heard at some
point um at the federal level the
pandemic response team had been you know
basically defunded and there wasn't a
lot of support for the Calamity that we
were facing at that time but when you
were developing well I guess when they
were developing the plan say in 2019
then they would have been looking at
Best
Practices for the time yep yep that's
correct okay thank you represent
leus thank you for coming thank you for
taking my question I just want to follow
up on R Martian's question is who what
bring it closer yes um who did make if
you said you made the operational policy
well who did make the underlying policy
which you were then
implementing can you clarify exactly
what you mean by policy so if you're
talking about executive orders and those
types of things well that would be the
governor yeah so a lot of like regarding
uh how policy came out or practices um
those came down from recommendations
from FEMA to the state level uh DHHS
would put it through the state their
stakeholder group bring it back to the
command you know the unified command to
say hey we should go this path and then
that was the implementation of that
policy was the way that would roll okay
thank you
yep represent Merchant thank you Madam
chair and thank you again director
buckon for thinking the question um one
of the things that I
think I learned from D diving into some
of the
detail is how well the state of New
Hampshire did nationally and which and
my measurement to say that is based upon
the fact of how many people died per
100,000 the only state that did better
than we did according to the data I read
was the state of Hawaii because they
could shut the island down so in saying
that I would say the state overall did a
fairly good job in managing the
resources it had to accomplish saving
lives in saying that as well given the
fact that there were things that
probably along the way that the unified
command or your
agency learned what worked well and what
did we learn from it that we could take
going forward with another pandemic
because I don't think this will be the
last one we're going to see yeah that
that's a that's a great uh question uh
and I couldn't agree with you more that
the work that the state of New Hampshire
did early into the response and the way
they set up the framework and how
aggressive they were in regards to
putting the unified command into place
uh really paid dividend as we moved into
what was started as a you know my wife's
a school teacher right so my my
threshold is yeah we're going to be out
of school for two weeks you know and I
have two kids that are in school right
so we're going to be out of school for
two weeks and we're going to back and
will be fine right and then that o
obviously blossomed um the state was
very aggressive about putting a
framework in place to be able to not
only support the local communities but
assist them in getting what they needed
to make sure that we could get the
schools open to make sure we could
provide those resources in an
environment that really
um changed every day right uh it it
truly changed every single day uh you
eoc's that were opening up in local
municipalities uh and you had folks in
the in roles that they had never truly
prepared for a and you had folks working
at the state level doing jobs that were
whether it was a call center or whether
it was uh a testing site and supporting
a testing site we
really the way the state approach this
and the Hands-On approach helped to save
and move things forward and be
successful
so I want to say thank you again yeah no
I appreciate
that represent
beler thank you madam chair um it's
going to take me a fair bit of research
to to figure out some of the things that
I'm looking for details on so I'm hoping
you can help me uh narrow this down a
little bit because you've said
that um generally speaking the
Department of Homeland Security of New
Hampshire falls more or less under the
direction of the federal ederal
Department of Homeland Security so I'm
looking do you do you have to know or
can you get to the committee what um
Federal Andor State statutes um
authorize the state uh organization to
be under a sort of direct incident or
direct command system from the federal
agencies yeah our our enabling
legislation could be found in 21p 21 P
thank you yep and it lays out the
requirements for planning and response
coordination
uh one sec yeah and if you look under 21
Peak especially colon 34 that really
talks about Homeland Security and
Emergency Management that helps a lot
okay and represent Belgium thank you
madam chair and and another question
totally unrelated to that one um you
mentioned that you're the DHS is
partnering regularly with the Department
of Health and Human Services and others
so I'm
curious uh because as as we've heard
before we may not have seen the end of
disease are there any current plans or
activations or anything of that nature
underway right now for the current
outbreak of Aven
flu it's a great question and I at this
point looking over my memory bank we
don't have an exercise in place right
now thank you
yep represent po off
[Music]
thank you uh Madame chair thank you for
being here and taking my question so
following up on previous question for
future uh medical emergencies what
exactly triggers uh your department
involvement uh is it national emergency
declaration or is it some State local
declaration uh when you get
involved so you want to know when we
activate when we engage
so I'm going to try to narrow this down
because that's a pretty broad question
right so we talked about every every uh
disaster starts locally right so and and
we have different thresholds for how we
respond depending on the time of year
right so if I get up and I have 14,000
people without
power uh in June our response is not
going to be as uh we're going to be more
of a uh coordinating event instead of
having the EOC open um based on the fact
that it's warm out right we want to get
power back to folks it's warm there's
heat the there's ability to have windows
open we really run into a
challenge in the middle of the winter
when we get and have 14,000 people
without power that's our threshold for
opening and we have a couple different
levels at which we open at so we have
what is called enhanced monitoring where
hscm will actually be in the the state
EOC monitoring it monitoring what's
happening in the field that's a big
that's a big definition there right so
we come in and we enhanc monitor what's
taking place um if we need to go to a
partial
activation that means that we're
bringing in more than
two um
stakeholders into the OC so that means
I'm bringing bringing in say I'm going
to use the power example again because
it's the most common here in New
Hampshire you would bring in the energy
sector we would bring in DHHS who gives
us a hand with um Sheltering uh we would
bring in our Communications Group and
911 group and we bring in State Police
because that's how we deal with our
communication level we would also
activate our local liaz online which is
going to provide direct access for any
Community put a need in and and contact
us directly okay um and then from there
if we need to get more than you know uh
a couple esfs together then we really
look at like hey it's time to Pivot and
go to a full activation okay and that
conversation really starts um not only
with our office but having further
conversation with the governor like hey
here here's what we're seeing this is
what we're forecasting and this is how
we believe we need to bring this under
control because we don't live we don't
live in a a vacuum right we live in a a
very open uh communicative uh response
mode and get that
out representative Merchant thank you
madam chair and thank you Mr backton
taking the
question I want to drill back into what
representative belter talked about and
that's back to the governance if you
will of the agency and I'm not really
sure I understand it completely there is
the federal level as also the state
level so what role is a federal
government doing as far as the
governance of your agency versus the
state level is it really coming more
into funding or do they actually as some
would say calling the shots and telling
the agency what to do is it really
coming back to the state and our own
state policymakers in our own state
government making those key decisions y
so to clarify that so the federal
government will give us guidance we
implement the guidance here we make the
decisions here locally uh really that
that is the decision that's made here in
the state of New Hampshire regarding
what we need what our needs are what our
needs are not and they help us with uh
from not only from the response side but
from the recovery side um so the
recovery side of the house really deals
with like hey what happens post post
incident how do we fix the roads how do
we do things and what's a recovery money
coming back into the state followup
thank you m chair so in saying that akin
to it would be not 100% comparable but
something like it it's kind of like the
National Guard where basically National
Guard is under the state control uh for
the most part unless it's federalized
but for the most part sort of sounds
like the same thing with the state
agency the federal government's there to
Resource it and provide policies and so
forth about how to use the resource but
they're not ultimately as I said before
telling the agency how to do something
representative eel thank you so I don't
know if you can um speak to this exactly
but that's the way it works I guess for
Homeland Security but when you're
talking when you're talking about uh
vaccin vaccine approvals and things of
that nature there's not really a role
for the state that sort of directive
comes from the federal government yeah
that's a much
larger if yeah much larger piece and
that would be authorized at the federal
level y right and so then it would just
be up to the state to how to implement
how to use those vaccines as part of its
response plan or how to implement and
how to distribute implementation and
distrib so not assessment of their
validity but implementation and
distribution okay then I have just
another question so you know part of our
job here is to assess the efficacy of
the New Hampshire
response and we had been told that
actually your um your department was
doing exactly the same thing so is that
part of your development of a new
Emergency Management plan or are you
doing a separate kind of report
assessing the covid response yep the
state of New Hampshire is under contract
with a company called Title Basin uh and
for the last 12 months they have been
doing working through the after action
review process for
covid-19 and not only looking at um not
only looking at the response but
basically saying hey here here were the
shortcomings or here are the the
Improvement areas to help us grow right
that report is actually due out the end
of this month uh and um so that is not
available
yet um when that is available uh do you
do you think you could send a copy to
our committee once it's accepted and
made public yeah that' probably be
available when would when do you think
that might be it's coming in the end of
June um we'll go through a review
process get it to the governor's office
and it's really their report you know um
and and I don't really have a timeline
on that yet sorry um I know you don't
have a timeline um but your review
process what are you thinking it's going
to take month two months yeah I would I
would assume that our seop update will
uh wait not wait but we get started and
then we'll review that after action re
review and see what pieces we need to
put into place into the updated plan so
we'll wait before we finish our work on
updating the Emergency Operations plan
um so I guess my more specific question
was regarding the report itself um it's
due out the end of June um and and it
has to go through a review process
obviously your department is going to
have a re piece in that reviewing it
what is your time your Department's
timeline do you have a a deadline of
when you going to have that review
completed so once I have the report in
hand it'll become a top priority to to
read and get our folks engaged on what
that looks like and get stakeholders at
the table that need to review that
report thank you representative
beler thank you madam chair and I think
now that we have a little bit of a a
better concept of the the command
structure and how and how that portion
went I'd like to get a little bit into
um sort of enforcement mechanisms and
what sort of enforcement uh actions um
fall under the Department of Homeland
Security regarding anything to do with
response um so you're really talking
about what enforcement capabilities come
under underneath the governor's office
through the state of
emergency uh and that is really where
that is driven from uh and that is
uh underneath the governor's powers and
underneath the state of emergency Powers
uh that he has the ability to
enforce um enforce certain things and
inverse La enforce law and that
obviously is enabling legislation for
him to empower those those
things uh
yeah so there is a section called govern
Governor Duty and it's uh
21 p uh col 43- a um just for for
reference uh represent Bel you have a
followup yes thank you madam chair and
uh thank you for help to clarify the the
source of the uh Authority I'd like to
go a little bit deeper if you if you can
if you're prepared to have um any
information on what um sort of specific
enforcement actions May have fallen
under the Department of Homeland
Security that may have been taken um as
a part of any of the orders or anything
else that was occurring under uh covid
response yeah so what I can tell you is
under um chapter four the powers of the
governor's are Governor uh for semicolon
45 it outlines the state of emergency
practices and what and what the governor
is able to empower and go from there
regarding what hscm directly during the
co response was responsible from an
enforcement standpoint I can't answer
that question as I sit here today
without going back and reviewing um so I
apologize followup yes and just if if uh
at any point you were um any of your
people could get some information to
this committee on specific actions that
were taken by DHS that would be very
helpful to us thank you represent
Merchant thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking the question um given that
there's a contract with tile basin
I'm assuming having worked on some of
these contracts myself there's going to
be a saving of Works something which the
contractor is supposed to be assessing
and what their obligations are under the
contract is that statement to work
somewhere publicly because it must have
gone through the governor in Council in
order for that contract to be reviewed
and where will we find it yeah I I don't
have the contract with me but I believe
that that would be something that you
could get from administrative Services
that's a contract that was signed by the
agency uh and available publicly and
that would go through the department of
administrative services with
commissioner Arling house yep and then
follow by May what I'm trying to get to
is trying to understand under that
report when it comes out again back to
that fundamental question I asked before
are they trying to assess the
operational response or trying to assess
the policy that were put into place that
were operationalized on both of them
that's what I'm trying to get to do you
know at this point in time what the
intent of the report was it was looking
strictly at how we responded and used
the resources or basically at that point
in time how we set some policies yeah I
think it looked at how we responded it
did not um look at individual policy I
don't believe uh but I don't have the
scope in front of me to 100% answer that
representative eel um I think getting
that contract with the scope of services
and everything would be really really
helpful um I think it's fair D to say
that as a committee it's really
difficult for us without staff to assess
the response so I'm curious just
generally do do you know what the cost
of the the contract was and obviously
you folks didn't have the and it's also
good to have an objective Observer I
know but I'm sure you folks didn't have
the staff to do it it sounds like a huge
undertaking yeah it it is is a huge
undertaking um I used to know that
number but I apologize that that is you
have a ballpark yeah I don't I I I would
it was over $100,000 for sure yeah yeah
um and it's a Year's worth of it's a
Year's worth of work Year's worth of
work and I just so we had gotten this
from um uh Trisha Tilly when she
described what you were covering I had
and what she said was preparedness comp
command communication decision Mak
financial management health and medical
Logistics public private Partnerships
and public information do that sound
that's what you expected me to speak to
this morning no I just I just I mean
it's an incredibly comprehensive report
and and I think based on our mission
we're just you know we're it's a it's a
narrower analysis yeah um but I think
from from our perspective whatever that
report reveals will be hugely uh yeah
will be hugely helpful and I think part
of the
chair's questioning was because we
basically are looking at an early
November time frame if we were going to
make any recommendation so we're hoping
that we get something really uh good and
useful uh before we are supposed to take
some action okay thanks I did take a
note regarding the scope of the process
so
hopefully to help you with that
representative Merchant thank you uh in
regards to this kind of analysis being
done at the state level with the Title
Basin
contractor can you comment about is this
something unique to New Hampshire or
other states doing the same kind of
Journey what I'm trying to get to if
there other states doing it it'd be
interesting to see how our evaluation
done through title basement May compare
to some of the other states least some
of the key IND ators within those
reports yeah I I think that um the after
action review process uh in the
Emergency Management Field is something
that we seek out a lot right you know um
so yes other states are doing reviews uh
other states have completed their
reviews already uh and um this is the
process this is one of the services that
Title Basin provides and they've done
other states on top of that followup
thank you Mr chair Madam chair so in
saying that I mean I would find it very
interesting to look at how Title
Basin looks at and analyzing our
response but more importantly how that
is compared to some of the other states
that they have possibly done and what
were the strengths that we had what were
the weaknesses we had and try to
understand from that point of view is
this is what we did how does it stand up
against what other states have done
because I think at the end of the day is
we're trying to measure our response but
not do it in the vacuum but trying to do
it in a more
comprehensive um analysis not just
internally but also externally across
the
country yes I agree with that repres P
off thank you Madame chair um my
question is uh about implementation I
understand that on federal level um uh
to implement the decisions uh they were
managing uh uh different
uh um there was uh there always uh some
fractions who fighting against it so
they were managing how information is
being spread and identifying some
misinformation and on the federal level
they have
cisa um the cyber security and
infrastructure Security Agency and the
Federal
uh Department of Homeland Security who
is helping with that so I wonder how uh
it's happening on state level under your
department uh do you have any
involvement when you implement certain
decision uh um uh do do you identify
some information and some uh how to
fight misinformation how it's happening
uh here yeah yeah so we work very
closely with sisa today in regards to
how to make sure that we're getting out
the the right pieces of information um
and uh you know the federal government
has provided a lot of resources to us to
make sure that we are um our cyber
security pieces are secure make sure
that we have gu you know guidance to
help communities develop uh the the if
you think about where we were uh March
of
2020 uh regarding technology and where
we are today the utilization of
technology has just blossomed over time
you know I I can tell you that I have
two kids at home that are very they
would tell you what did covid-19 do for
them they got cell phones because they
needed to be able to talk with their
friends right that was very important to
us but that utilization of of Technology
doesn't come without its own risks right
you know and how how information is
pushed out and how we're verifying
information and and we uh really uh try
to drill down and make sure that we're
pushing out uh appropriate information
that can be validated uh and go from
there so everything that we came in
comes in has a source and and make sure
that we're making a decision on quality
pieces of
leus so who made the decisions as to
what information was being put out was
that you or was that coming from
elsewhere and then you were just making
sure that it was going out or how did
that work so there was a uh Joint
Information Center or the J as it's
called is attached to the
um attached to the unified command and
their job is to deal with the messaging
piece and I think if you recall and I'm
I'm
just from a 30,000 foot level because I
wasn't involved in the day today
conversations but if you look at it uh
one of the one of the
successes that I see as a as a as S as a
local official at the time but as a
taxpayer here in the state was the
amount of um press conferences that were
held to push information out really was
an idea or a theory to get quality
information out as fast as we could and
though that was pushed together and how
they reviewed that internally was
basically pushed through that joint
information Center and then verified by
the subject matter experts that were
advising the governor you know whether
it was the Health and Human Services uh
recommendation that came in or whether
it was an emergency management that uh
recommendation that came in all of those
came things come in and and a decision
is made because at some point there
needs to be uh DEC confliction done to
make sure we stay in line with where we
want to be as a state uh and then from
there we push information out and I'm
not telling you folks anything you don't
know we're a very locally controlled
state right so we want to get
information down so the local uh
government leaders can make the best
decision for their communities so it's a
trickle down
process
followup thank you um I just want to
drill down into that some because as
we've had various speakers in um there
was information that was available that
was not being put out that could have
been very
useful and so the question is
who was kind of the gatekeeper on that
who decided whether the information was
good information or bad information who
decided which information to push and
which to kind of Silence so from a
day-to-day operational piece through the
covid-19 response I really can't comment
on that because I was not in this role
at that time I was not engaged in that
conversation would that be something you
could find out and send to us I can ask
the question thank you uh I would assume
that from a communication standpoint
that that will be something that is
reviewed in the after action review
thank
you represent p is
off
so on our during our previous committee
meetings uh uh we heard uh that
uh um under governor in in New Hampshire
there is a tenden to stick with
decisions that were initially made uh so
I wonder if you would agree with this
and my concern is for example with Co
response science was changing very
rapidly initially we were hoping that
vaccines will stop transmission then at
some point science discovered that they
do not stop transmission but because
there was tendency on federal level on
local level to stick with with decisions
that were made like there was like it
was a long process and backing up to my
previous question like if uh if if if
something was identified as misinform
misinformation but the science already
changed and maybe uh it's actually not
misinformation but we are still sticking
to the old decision I see a problem in
it so
what your thought on it and uh any would
you agree that New Hampshire tends to
stick with old
decisions so I don't know that that's a
question that I
can give you a quality answer on um but
I would share that if you look at what
was taking place during the covid-19
response um I think um You probably
heard this a couple of different times
but it was
literally like flying a plane and
building it at the same time if you look
at the way you did things in your home
at the beginning of covid-19 and the way
you approached them at the end were far
different you know um if you look at the
way things were done at local
municipalities um at at the beginning of
covid-19 versus the end of covid-19 what
were the communities that pivoted uh to
take new information into
consideration um and do things like
opening Town Halls back up and how they
were processing information um that I
think you would see across the state was
at different levels you know uh and and
that is where that local control really
drives that that bus and that is a
decision that is made made
locally represent
beler thank you madam chair and I want
to follow up a little bit on sort of
that same line of um of qu quiry because
part of the part of the charge of this
group is going to be to try to see if
there might be any recommendations to be
made for future events that could occur
so without looking just without
necessarily looking specifically to what
happened in covid but more just asking
your overall impression um do you feel
like the
current organizational
structure is such that it's sufficiently
Nimble to be be able to adapt to
changing circumstances that occur in in
an emergency type such as a pandemic and
do you and the second part of that is do
you believe that or do you see any way
that there might be recommendations made
to
um to make alterations that would allow
for um for new science and new
information to be adopted in a in a
rather rapid manner manner um because as
as I think we all know there can
sometimes be a tendency within
bureaucrat bureaucracy to to have a
difficult time adapting so do you do you
have any recommendations or do you see
any any ways to maybe uh make things
better yeah so I
think I think you're talking about
communication right and how we how we
you know it comes down to how do we
communicate right I I would share with
you that one of the most enjoyable parts
to my job is the fact that I have direct
access into the governor's office and
with every commissioner across the state
of New Hampshire uh so if I need to have
communication or I need to get a piece
of information out or verify a piece of
information it is literally One Call
Away when you're under a response model
where you're in a unified command that
that is something that helps you because
the network is already created before
the incident really takes place uh if
you look at the State of New Hampshire
that is not just something that happened
after the pandemic uh emergency manage
Homeland Security and Emergency
Management in the state is very active
part o of what happens we we really
coordinate a lot of things whether it's
uh talking about the Nascar race that'll
be two weeks from now or uh a snowstorm
or a flooding event like we have direct
access to everybody to be able to have
that conversation so I do believe that
we have the ability to be nimble uh the
the question regarding like Hey how do
we move this forward I think one of the
things that I come into this chair uh
still fairly fresh is like hey we
recognize that there has been turnover
across the state that means that we need
to put training and exercise and
development work together to make sure
that we're pulling that together uh and
and what does that look like and how do
we work with those Partners like public
health because you have the regional
Public Health Network that is in the
field day in and day out partnering and
and our goal is to bring the local
communities together so you have public
health the municipalities and the
schools and try to get them under one
tent and be able hey how are we going to
how are we going to address this issue
what does that look like from a workshop
to a tabletop we we're in a room to a
fullscale exercise really is the goal
moving forward we house a a training
exercise and Development Group within
our within our agency uh in their task
with uh everything um from a Hazmat
incident all the way through an active
ass salent drill so those touch points
are taking place and we partner with
commissioner Weaver and her staff and
Steph lock and that group uh to really
bring that together because we're not
going to stand by ourselves we can't
work in a vacuum right so we're very
very open in communicating pushing the
requests across and supporting because
we as I go back to where I was I don't
know how long almost an hour ago now um
we're supportive in nature to help the
communities move the initiatives
forward represent vble so this is a
really broad question when when you um
initially spoke you said that you were
in the role you were not in the role um
during the pandemic that you are in now
and you could speak to it more as a
customer rather than and I would say if
there's a weakness in in the folks that
we haven't had come and testified us
it's we haven't really heard from munici
M municipalities so much so um what is
there something you would like to share
what you thought was done well what you
didn't um I'll just throw that open yeah
no I I think I appreciate that question
um because it it is a challenge right to
hear from 234 different
communities in regards to what that
looks like um I would share that I
thought the state did a tremendous job
in pushing information out so we could
make decisions at the local level and
how do you pivot to be able to provide
services to the
constituents and and make it successful
and make it safe um so I think
communication wise and logistically we
did a very good job I could literally go
in put an order in you know very short
order after March if we were running
short on a piece of equipment I could
put in you know hey what's the status on
masks like in the next day be like hey
meet the National Guards person over at
the exit 6 um DMV facility and they're
going to be there doing your
distribution your order will be there or
if you need something earlier drive up
to the warehouse and we'll get it and
they had put processes in place and if
you think about
that those are all things that show how
Nimble we can be as a state because
those processes and taking a National
Guards person and basically saying hey
can you stand this process up I'm sure
there were some that were like they
didn't review this in training right
like how we and this is in my real in my
real world job I'm a project manager so
I use those skills to help make us
successful and that's really the key to
the success in this state and to have
that Hands-On approach from the uh the
governor's office on down to be engaged
in what was happening uh and and have
him talking with the fire chiefs with
the Emergency Management directors with
law enforcement the public health
officers that that was important so I
think we did a pretty good job from that
and
and it was such a
large response that you know we were all
kind of growing at the same time so
followup so I didn't hear anything
negative there was there anything you
wish we'd done
better um recognizing your current
position yeah no I I get that yeah no I
get that um what could be you know I
think that
um obviously the challenges regarding
executive order and policy and those
types of things um certainly become an
implementation piece uh that's debated
so it's debated here and then it's
debated locally
and and the communication was very good
getting information down but what was
the breakdown below so it was more below
um I would say but then once we got over
that it was good so I don't really have
anything okay represent
Merchant thank you madam chair and also
director buckon I want to follow on that
question or the response to the question
communication in your
opinion was the fundamental issue about
the how things were being handled from
an operational point of view of getting
resources to the communities or more
about the policy that was being
communicated down local municipalities
because there's a difference between
agreeing with the resources we need in
order to get the vaccine whatever else
we need versus the policy behind that
because if the policy was really what
was being Deb deed at the local level
throughout the state that's a different
issue than how we respond to it and I
want to be clear we're talking about how
we respond to it not debating the policy
yeah yeah no it was the response it was
the operational piece it was the
implementation it wasn't like we weren't
um opening up new debate on policy that
level represent po off thank you Madame
chair thank you Buon different question
in the beginning of your testimony you
mentioned that
75% of people in your department are new
people uh and they joined uh uh in less
than three years and um I wonder how
it's compared to other department and
was it always like this is it something
new does it do you know reasons does it
have anything to do with like I don't
know Co response B out something no no
that's a great it's a great question um
I I would say that it's probably
multifaceted right you had folks that at
the end of the covid-19 response
were ready to go
home they they were ready to be home for
a while right and and you saw some
retirements and folks that were in uh
key positions within the state that have
moved on uh and and that is just comes
from the work the the human body can
only work at a rate for so long before
it needs to take a break right um we
also have had a host of Staff internally
to
HSM um because of the covid-19 response
that has actually moved on to go to work
for the federal government they're
actually working for FEMA now uh because
you're talking about a branch of FEMA uh
from a public assistance standpoint that
was non-existent prior to
covid-19 um and uh those
opportunities have provided career
growth uh for folks that really got into
this business to see their careers grow
and some of that was a natural path and
and then you probably had some folks who
were like yeah I don't want to do that
anymore and and just found a different
path and moved on so um but overall I
would say the change over in the staff
uh has been something of a natural
progression you know and folks take
different opportunities want to do a
different style of work because um
leus I still want to go down that uh
policy path if you don't
mind and so your department your job
really is implementation of the policy
and you didn't open up anything to
question that policy you went with
whatever so I want to just so we know
that in the in the future of this
committee that we're talking to the
right people as far as policy so the
governor
obviously
DHHS who else would have been I mean
policy came from federal right but then
as far as for our
state in deciding whether to follow the
Fed policy not um what parts we were
going
to who was developing it that you then
had to implement I guess so that we can
make sure we talk to those people yeah
so I would go right back to where we
started when we identified the unified
command folks right so you had uh the
Department of Health and Human Services
you had hscm and you had the National
Guard uh um you know in the in the
unified command role Prov providing
support to the governor uh I can't
answer on a day-to-day basis who else
they sought uh subject matter expertise
from um but I can tell you from a
fundamental foundational level those
were the three ke key agencies that
helped develop things to move forward
thank you very
much representative eel thank you so
much for all these questions a lot of
times we're just sitting here listening
but not
today um so I I actually I don't know a
lot about Homeland Security uh when it
was actually created in the state of New
Hampshire
um and 200 when 2002 2002 um it
obviously must have
evolved uh I wondered who the homeland
security uh head was during the time of
the um pandemic and I wondered if you
could just speak generally about the
history and maybe how it's evolved since
Co that sort of thing yeah so um I I'll
take you back a little further than that
even good so pre
911 um Homeland Security did not exist
in the federal government right um 911
really catapulted the opportunity to
create the division of Homeland Security
at the federal level um but the state of
New Hampshire had a dual uh hated
agency um and it actually started out as
a civil defense back you know the old
days Right started as civil defense and
then uh for those that have been in
their chairs for a while a gentleman by
the name of Don Bliss who was a State
Fire Marshal uh actually was the fire
marshal and the Emergency Management
director for the state after 911
happened um Chris Pope who was the uh
EMD for the city of conquered actually
came in and was part of the uh
formalization of the homeland security
and Emergency Management Group okay uh
what's changed since then I would tell
you the landscape of Homeland Security
and Emergency Management in the country
is a landscape that is evolving today uh
if you look at uh the number of uh
storms that we're having you look at the
uh number of other um security functions
that we're dealing with um you know
surrounding and supporting uh multiple
different venues in regards to how we
deal with cyber security now that is an
Annex that is coming into the is part of
the state Emergency Operations plan you
know 20 years ago that would have never
been a piece of that right um we didn't
even understand what the impacts of that
were so we are we are an agency that
really puts a lot of people in the room
to put plans together for bad days and
that's really the goal to make sure we
are on that Cutting Edge to make sure
we're bringing those folks together and
we we're the coordinating
arm follow
up
um so in developing the next Emergency
Management plan for the State of New
Hampshire it sounds like that's going to
look quite a bit different and be far
broader because it'll I because climate
change there's huge storm response
issues which isn't our purview thank the
Lord uh um but then you're going to have
an aspect of that that will be pandemic
or Health crisis yeah a broader one
presumably than what you have and we'll
work that with our stakeholder groups
right so the Department of Health and
Human Services will be key stakeholders
and bringing that together and helping
us develop that that none of this gets
done in vacuum you really make sure that
you're getting the right people in the
room to help develop their because they
have to take ownership of those things
we can only be the subject matter expert
of so many so many points they need to
take ownership of those responses and
help develop those plans and I assume
there might be legislative
recommendations perhaps as part of that
or or I I would assume over time you
you'll see some of
oh represent
cran thank you thank you for taking my
question I'm still trying to formulate
it so forgive me um just going back to
the the sort of personnel turnover piece
that we were talking about earlier um do
you feel are there takeaways from covid
in terms of where we need to be with
with Staffing or um things that we
should sort of activate with you know
maybe emergency hiring things like that
and in the event
of sort of a a long emergency like yeah
no I I appreciate that question um I
tell stakeholder groups this a lot
Emergency Management is the best team
sport in
existence and it and is truly a team
sport right um our job at at Homeland
Security emergency management is to
provide the framework to bring the
subject matter experts in and and
coordinating their messaging and making
sure we're getting information out uh
certainly uh currently today we have 15
open Federal
disasters so on the recovery side of the
house you look at what does that mean
and covid-19 is one of those disasters
okay so what does that mean that means
that we're working with FEMA uh last
month I believe they pushed out almost
$8 million in disaster relief from the
federal government here
locally um so those are the areas that's
really the long-term recovery piece that
becomes a mechanism of of challenge the
good news is is that we also receive
management costs from the federal
government to manage those things here
locally uh so we have that nimbleness to
help bolster that when we need to um we
run a pretty lean agency and and that's
helps us to provide a more a customer
service that is very you know it's not
uncommon for somebody to pick up and
call me you know I'm not insulated from
that nor do I want to be insulated from
that I want to be available and making
sure that they're getting what they need
and that's an important part of the job
so I I think for purposes of our
discussion I think um that I'm going to
read um 21p col 34 what the purpose of
Homeland Security and Emergency
Management is and maybe
if the definition may need to be changed
or tweaked in the future but I think it
would really help us understand um and
what it says is um because of the
possibility of the occurrence of natural
and human-caused
disasters resulting from fire flood
hurricane earthquake prolonged power
outages disruption or contamination of
the food or water supply degradation of
critical facilities in vital systems
disruption of communication systems or
other natural technological or human
causes including acts of
terrorism in an order that the state of
New Hampshire will be adequately
prepared to quot with such disasters and
generally in order to preserve the lives
and the property of the people of the
state a state division of Emergency
Services Communications and management
is hereby created under the direction of
the director of the division of Homeland
Security and Emergency
Management the Emergency Management
Powers provided in this subdivision are
conferred upon the governor and upon
other executive heads of governing
bodies of the state the creation of
local organizations for emergency
management and in political subdivisions
of the state is authorized and provision
is made for the rendering of mutual
Aid
among uh this subdivision in the policy
of the state
that all Emergency Management functions
of the state be coordinated to the
maximum extent with the comparable
functions of the federal government
including its various departments and
agencies of other states and localities
and of private agencies of every type to
the end that the most effective
preparation and use may be made of the
nation's Manpower resources and
facilities for dealing with any disaster
or incident of terrorism that may occur
it's pretty broad um and it encompasses
a lot but I think um it's really
important to understand what the purpose
of the department is um and also stated
at the beginning of this was that every
Community I believe in New Hampshire
please correct me if I I missp speake um
has an emergency management unit in
place I know know in my town of
Barnstead we do have people that head
that up and I think in other towns there
are Point people in place um it is a
requirement for every Community to have
an emergency management director if the
governing agency Board of selectman Town
Council fail to appoint somebody they
they take on that responsibility until
such time that they appoint
somebody representative eel um just
getting back again to the to the uh
feeling of the localities to how it all
rolled out do you I mean you've G you've
shared your views do you think there's
response groups in the towns I mean if
not that's fine but I was just curious
yeah I think um my recommendation would
be um that I believe that was part of
the scope of the the after action so I
think that there's probably some let's
see what comes out of the the report
report mechanism and and then go from
there just as a fall is there a an orc
chart for horand security just so we
could sort of see I'm is it is it
closely held or is it something we could
see we we certainly can provide that to
you that's not a big deal I just think
it would be interesting for us to kind
of understand this it can give you a
broad broad um broad level overview
okay represent
leus you said 8 million dollar had come
as still part of the cleanup can you
explain what type of things that that is
will will be spent for that that was in
one month that was in one month for 15
disasters right so probably for this
committee's view you the the question if
I was sitting on your side of the table
would be uh do you have an estimate as
to what the covid-19 response Public
Assistance was for the State of New
Hampshire and that number is over 300
million doll and and I guess partly I
was wondering if that's continuing to
come in because you said we're still
cleaning that up what type of things is
that being used for so those are the
money that is coming in is now
supporting projects that have been
completed right so you had projects that
were done during the co resp bonds that
are being scope continue to be scoped
and put in and now funded on the
backside whether a hospital needed to
Pivot and make a an adjustment um
because of covid-19 to a uh filtration
system or they needed to bring in
Staffing from another area the federal
government is providing assistance to
basically keep the hospitals from going
uh bankrupt U from supporting the
covid-19 response okay thank you and the
local communities right so whether it's
an EMS agency or a fire department or or
Community there may have been things
that they did that were eligible to
receive compensation back because they
were tied directly to uh the covid-19
response okay thank you so it's kind of
retrospective money at this point it it
is a 100% reimbursement based process
okay thank you so speaking on the
dollars and the reimbursement um now we
heard from commissioner Caswell that
uh they handled a lot of the funds of
dispersing um
monies uh but when we're talking about
hospitals is the money coming in from
the state and then being dispersed to
the hospitals or is it being dispersed
directly to them I guess is my question
so um you're talking about two separate
buckets of money uh commissioner Caswell
uh deals with the arpa funds as they may
be called and we're dealing with the
disaster of public assistance program
the public assistance program flows
directly from the federal government to
the state of New Hampshire and then we
distribute it out uh and and that is all
done through uh payments um as projects
are awarded and then we help support uh
the local communities to make sure that
they're getting their projects and
paperwork and receipts and all those
things that are needed to get their
money back from the federal government
we support that and that's paid for
through that management costs that we
talked about okay so it's uh that is
another aspect of what your department
yeah handles um do any of these do these
contracts and these monies have to be
approved by the executive Council yes
thank you representative e um so what's
going on at the federal level now um as
far as I mean are they doing sort of an
after action report on the pandemic uh
response and is that an ongoing process
have you guys been sent information more
information on best practices or what
what I guess I we're certainly not
looking at the federal government's
preparedness for the next pandemic but
what I was wondering is how much is
getting pushed down to the States or do
you anticipate more will be so I I
anticipate that as the federal
government continues to look at the
response through the what we'll call the
next chapter is going to be the closeup
process to covid-19 and they start
looking at like hey what worked what
didn't work that will in turn Drive
change to programs like public
assistance you know why did it take uh
uh 24 months to get a payment back to a
local community that had to expend local
dollars because they had an outbreak at
the local fire department and their EMS
agency would have not have been able to
be able to respond because all of their
workers were contaminated right so so
those types of changes the big picture
stuff that they're looking at we
participate
um we participate in giving them
feedback in regards to like hey we
really need this to change to be more
Nimble uh our goal is to like cut down
on the number of steps uh and make sure
that we're getting money into the right
possible represent
leus so besides communities does that
include schools or do does that money
also come through through you your
nonprofits represent Vel um so I guess
my question was maybe um I was wondering
from a health standpoint if they must be
looking
at I I I just don't know you know like
all the different aspects of how a
country responds to a pandemic not just
how the funding is pushed out but you
know anyway it's multifaceted yeah I
don't have an answer to that question
um
so you mentioned before that guidance
would come down from FEMA and I I
understand that you weren't in this role
during covid so um bear with me
um and
that do we just you kind of said we
so you have we had emergency
guidelines
[Music]
discerns if they're the right thing for
our state not only the right thing for
our state but is the information we're
getting
accurate um so I guess is what how do we
discern the difference yeah
um I'll try
I'll try uh so as information comes down
uh that would come in uh and the
stakeholder groups including uh heavily
relied on uh DHHS and you know we got to
know a couple of names very well um that
we saw each night talking about the the
science piece right um and and I'm sure
that they were providing input as to
what was going to work in New Hampshire
um but I was not in the room at that
time so
um and you mentioned that you were in uh
Incident Management and public health um
which role were you in during the covid
response I was the uh Emergency
Management director uh for the town of
Hudson through the co response okay um
and in that
role
um you you mentioned that there was a
lot of positives that there was a lot of
communication with um the state um uh
and that we were able to um react pretty
quickly uh to the needs of the
municipalities which I think is
fantastic
um but when you got
guidance from the
state do you have to implement the
guidance that is given or do you have
can you discern it uh take time to look
at it and see if it's it's what's best
for your community it would depend on
how it was
written if it was an executive order
that was coming down regarding something
in the Food Network you know we would
have to implement that there was you
know there was executive Waters that
came down and that's the way things
worked and that was okay because it
provided support when a community needed
to implement
something and then there were other
areas where we probably debated
at
length so just want to clarify just for
myself so if something came down an
executive order came down anyone in the
Emergency Management uh position in a
town uh there was that was it I mean the
executive order was the executive order
and that's that was basically what
needed to be followed um if it was
guidance when and that's where the
discernment could come in y okay thank
you
represent leus just to use Hudson as an
example since you were there and that's
town I'm just um I'm thinking about the
things that affected people in the
town more directly like who made the
decisions was that part of your job when
it came
to for instance during election time the
election time changed a lot how we ran
them than how we'd always done elections
before so where did those was that you
and the moderator correct correct we
provided support to the moderator by by
State Statute the moderator is in charge
of the election process
so figuring out how to run an election
uh in town meeting because we're a
Senate Bill 2 community in Hudson at
that time how to run town meeting uh and
get that done uh was done in coord ation
with the moderator uh and supportive in
nature to him so you would have given
advice but he would have made the final
decisions as how to do it okay thank you
yep representative eel Y and who was the
homeland security director at the time
of the pandemic the pandemic would have
been Jennifer Harper okay and then how
many employees do you have now I'm just
curious um so I would tell you fully
filled which we are in
uh we should be about
85 um and we're probably running about
uh 17 vacancies today um
so and is that quite a few more than
what were in place during the pandemic
or is it about the same pretty
consistent it's about the same yeah
pretty consistent if there's any area
that has grown it has been the recovery
branch and that is uh because of the
number of uh disasters that they're
handling at this point point we
specifically have a team that manages
just the covid-19 projects um because
they're very
you
it anybody else have any questions for
the
leus it's kind of a Statewide and
potentially a nationwide issue that all
the Departments everybody's seeing is
vacancies right and I'm wondering if you
had
specific
um ideas as to
what
is keeping you or from filling those
vacancies what are the issues that
you're running up against because that's
a general thing we need to address yeah
I think some of that is
um availability of
labor you know um if you look at
um Public Safety in general whether it's
Emergency
Management uh fire police EMS and you
look at the uh number of applicants
available um when I took my first
entrance exam a couple days ago uh there
was 900 of us for three jobs in the city
of nashwa at that point that took the
exam um you have uh departments in the
state on the fir side of the house that
have rolling application periods right
now uh and they're not receiving any
applications uh and and that's just from
the Avenue of like who's available and
what's a what's a requirement um and and
some of that comes from the vacancy rate
comes from the covid-19 burnout per se
uh my my daughter is gainfully employed
as a nurse today uh and you know she
didn't have to she went to school
through Co
but if you look at the vacancy rate in
the hospitals that that's it's all
related um and we have a group actively
working internally on how to do
Recruitment and Retention better uh to
make sure we're going out and we've
bolstered our intern program uh to make
sure we're bringing in college students
to provide opportunities for them to
come in and learn about Emergency
Management uh plumouth State uh UNH uh
Rivier College out of nsha three big
Homeland Security and emergency
management programs are run through
there so we try to partner with them as
best we can um
so follow up is there something we can
do as a state that would um that you
that not as I'm here today okay thank
you represent people so um just again
thinking about the pandemic uh response
is there somebody on the homeland
security staff that takes care of that
sort of an interface person from a
health standpoint or is that pretty much
DHHS that you bring in as a stakeholder
DHHS director buckon I'd TR like to
thank you for being here on a Friday
uh and uh it's been a pleasure um and I
can't really appreciate you being here
um I appreciate the opportunity I
appreciate the conversation and uh I've
got a couple of notes uh but we'll give
you as much support as we can thank you
weekend
um I think there's a couple people
people that have some things that uh on
the committee I know represent belra and
represent Merchant have some uh
paperwork that they would like to pass
around and
you uh seeing it's 11:30 I've been asked
for a quick uh uh break so uh why don't
on
e
yeah
perfect okay um good another a minute
but everyone's here so all right uh
representative Merchant um you sent out
some information that you like entered
into the record yes Mr chair um I
basically came across a report that was
recently published um dealing with this
relatively comprehensive review looking
at masks and face coverings and so forth
being helpful if you will in reducing
transmission of respiratory
infections including covid and I just
want to be sure that it's in a record
that we did look at this at least I did
I'm sharing with the community so you
folks can as well is that when you look
at mass and mass mandates and so forth
there's been some concern about the
effectiveness of those devices as well
as the mandates themselves so I just
want to enter into the record that a
comprehensive review it's a 65-page
report I handed to the chair I thought
i' saved the printer so not to give
everyone if you will a um copy of the
full report I do have a copy for
everyone which is the first couple Pages
report thank you representa Merchant and
if you could just uh if you have a
chance to email the comprehensive report
to the spe the committee uh that would
be wonderful and that way we can make
sure that um it gets uploaded uh when
all the other documents get uploaded
into the uh website so that we have that
there
you do you want to have any further
discussion on this or are you all set or
no just I know if the committee wanted
to uh speak to this or at all or wanted
some time to digest it and come back
whenever we come back and talk about the
merits of the report and how it fits
into what we are trying to accomplish
here with our committee absolutely um
represent
Belcher thank you madam chair and I i'
I've just barely started to review this
a little bit but uh I I want to see if
my understanding is the same as as other
people's understanding on this which is
this is a uh retrospective meta
analysis um of various study is looking
at masking and its effect on the uh
transmission of um respiratory
viruses um both in the clinical and
separately in the non-clinical public
settings and if I may summarize what I'm
what I'm finding is that according to
this study and I I haven't had a chance
to dive deep into it but the the summary
suggests that the findings are that um
non-surgical
fairly high level n95 and higher masks
that are done through proper fit testing
do have the capacity to reduce
transmission uh but it does not have
those findings for surgical or cloth or
other U masks that were generally
available to the public during the
pandemic is that is that correct I think
it's a fair statement I would say that
what they're referring to is when you
use an appropriate mask and you use it
appropriately it does reduce the
transmission so that's really the C of
the report and I want to be clear about
that we're not talking about a cloth
covering we're talking about it
n95 thank you and represent
catean um thanks this is um actually the
one that I had sent out as well um there
should be an email with a nice actually
T Twitter thread from the first author
um that kind of like walks through the
the findings if anyone's interested in
that or or would find that maybe easier
um one thing that I did want to
highlight from this I think they do a
really good job of walking through some
of the challenges in um doing real world
tests of of masking um particularly a
lot of the you know studies that they
looked at um difficult to I guess look
at the outcomes because they're looking
at you know adherence rates of you know
40% things like that so it is really
hard to tell um how effective even those
like cloth masks are um they
did do a
fairly um or sorry they they did mention
one study that was like a community
study that was done in Bangladesh that
they highlight as having had um better
methodology I think than some of the
other studies that were out there and
showed that even with like an uptake
rate of 45% or something like that in
the community related to 10% in the
non-intervention group um they did see
significant um reductions in
transmission reductions in deaths and um
symptomatic illness during covid um
so sorry even even partial uptake of uh
some of the available masks did have uh
an effect they said although obviously
n95s are better hopefully I'm
articulating that well if I can follow
up on the comment if you look at one of
the key factors they talked about in
here was that it does provide a social
cultural symbol to remind people the
importance of what's going on so even
though per se it may not be 100%
effective in transmission of the disease
or the respiratory infection it does
provide a reminder to people about the
seriousness of what we're talking about
so from a social point of view and a
cultural point of view there is barit
that in of in of in of it by itself
thank you for that I think that uh for
me I'm going to have to take some time
to uh really look at this and review it
it's a lot of information to go over so
um maybe when we come back in September
um we can have this as a topic of uh
discussion representative eel yeah I
just wanted to thank uh representative
Merchant and chisan for their for
bringing this forth I mean I think we've
had a lot of
testimony from folks who uh
questioned uh some of the standard
operating procedure during the pandemic
the vaccin the vaccine policies or the
vaccination policies the masking
policies I don't think we've had much
testimony that we've taken that has sort
of uh supported how the government did
roll out its programs so this is one bit
of evidence that I think is really
helpful for us to consider and I and I
do very much look forward to this after
action report that they're preparing now
I think uh from a science-based
standpoint I'll be really helpful
absolutely uh representative beler did
introduce oh we you have a letter that
uh sorry I spaced out on that one for a
second thank you um so as as we had
previously discussed um we had
considered the idea of sending out um
a committee request for information um
documents and whatnot based on some of
the testimony we've received so we can
have a a more complete picture um and
take more things into consideration
within our record so I've drafted up a
uh something to consider um sending off
to the uh federal government
particularly the uh Departments of uh uh
Federal Food and Drug Administration as
well as the Centers for Disease Control
and prevention um requesting simply
asking questions of them and requesting
some information regarding such things
as um their vsafe um data uh and the
like um so everyone should have a copy
of that represent Merchant thank you
madam chair and thank you for bringing
this letter to us uh representative
Belcher I have a fundamental question is
how this letter ties back into the
charge that was provided to us than the
RSA because I look at the charge and
I'll read it to the committee
collectively the bipartisan committee
has tasked with investigating and
evaluating the state's response to co I
don't know how this is going to help us
with the evaluation of the state's
response I think it gets into maybe the
validity of the resources the state used
to respond to it but I don't know how it
actually supports our underlying Mission
here which is to respond to the state
and how the state responded to it versus
dealing with the tools or the
resources the state had available to it
and how they were utilize so this to me
is more about what tools we had
available versus how we utilize the
tools so help me understand that um I I
represent beler do you want to go ahead
yes I I would be absolutely happy to
address that um and so as we've heard so
so frequently in testimony from
organizations as diverse as today from
the Department of Homeland Security to
Department of Health and Human Services
um very much of the the St in point for
the recommendations made by uh our state
agencies as a part of this Co response
originated with federal agencies and
involved um Federal uh law and actions
um and in this particular case we we
know that the Department of Health and
Human Services um was reliant on
recommendations coming from both the CDC
as well as the FDA and others regarding
its particular recommendations for covid
vaccination if you if you were to now go
to the um website for the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
uh you will find that they are
recommending um the covid vaccine for
certain age groups and in certain
circumstances um and this was something
that began in the immediate roll out of
these uh of the vaccines and other and
other products um and if you look
currently at the recommendations for
children on the New Hampshire Department
of Health and Human Services website
regarding the covid-19 vaccines they
link directly to the CDC recommendations
as their own recommendations so in this
case there's really very little daylight
between what was being recommended in
the official actions of the State of New
Hampshire and what was coming down as as
recommendations and in some cases
perhaps more than recommendations
uh from the federal government um and
further this request ties directly into
um testimony we received in order to try
to determine the veracity of the
testimony the genuiness of some of the
documents we've been provided um and
fill in some of the gaps that may be
present in that information thank you
represent
Merchant thank you for that it helps me
to understand your point of view I will
say I totally disagree with it I think
it's outside of the scope of this
committee it is talking about the merits
the veracity of the resources which are
determined by the quote federal
government um as so I wanted to talk to
represent sorry director Bexton be clear
we not here I don't believe talk about
the policy issues but dealing with the
response which is dealing things
operationally and to me this is getting
more into a policy discussion than it is
to an operational discussion about how
the state responded to it so that's what
I'm trying to understand is that I see
this is really going beyond the scope of
our committee and therefore I I can't
support
it
so in testimony um one of the things
we're tasked with is the emergency youth
auth
authorization
and one of the questions is is
given and I guess maybe this be question
for DHHS is did they look at the data or
did they just accept that it was an
emergency use
authorization when there was testing out
there and data out
was not known to the public um but yet
these agencies knew about it they were
doing testing um and then they were
changing their protocols which would fly
in the face of a science-based
um you know when you're collecting
science you have a couple of pro
protocols that you're following so that
you can get your answers and if you
don't like your answers you just you
don't change Midstream and one of the
things
um that we're talking about and that
represent Bel was talking about was
vsafe um and that was concerning so I
guess the question is is when it comes
to an emergency use authorization and
we're following as the state a
directive from the federal
government are we Discerning that or are
they giving us all the are they giving
our agencies the accurate information so
that they can do what's best for our
state
I think it's kind of intertwined
unfortunately
um but it goes to the emergency use
authorization portion of this um and
with Federal guidance um
and we need as a committee need to
understand did the federal government
withhold information from our
agencies because if they weren't giving
all the facts how could they have
best how could any anybody in the state
do what's best for its citizens if
they're not giving all the
facts so representative leus
representative eel and then represent
Merchant um if you have bad policy it
doesn't matter how good you're or great
or fantastic your implementation is if
you have bad policy bad things are going
to happen so I think it's very important
for us to look at how we evaluated the
policy you know did we just take
somebody else's word for it and not look
at it and just implement it or did we
actually and do we have in place a way
of evaluating those policies coming from
outside of our state to
determine you know is that appropriate
is that appropriate for us Etc and I
think unless we look at the policies and
the way they were
evaluated and Etc we could end up going
down in the future a very bad Road
perfectly implementing very bad policy
I'm not saying that's what we did but I
think that's why I think it's important
to look at both policy and
procedure
represent um thank you and in I I
do agree with representative Merchant I
feel that this is outside the scope of
our view I understand that the actions
that were being taken were were
basically undergirded by the by the
federal advice that we were given but
that was the basically the land of the
lay of the land during the pandemic and
that's what we were dealing with um as
far as the letter itself is concerned um
I I really appreciate the thought and
the effort that went into it but the
inquiry is basically a Freedom of
Information Act inquiry I think if it's
going to go forward it should be handed
l in that way number one um I can't
imagine uh and then looking at the end
of it we we want we request access to
all Communications from any Personnel
within your agencies to all of these
questions posed from all periods 2020 to
the present I mean I just can't even
imagine the mountain of information uh
that we are requesting how long it would
take for this to be processed and what
we would even do with it if we got all
the information that we're requesting I
mean we're I certainly feel totally
incapable of assessing um the
information that we would be getting and
I I just I am not uh comfortable sending
this out as a request from the committee
if there are committee members that want
to pursue it on on their own I mean
that's obviously their right but I'm not
comfortable with this letter coming from
the committee thank you and represent
poof thank you madam chair uh uh I agree
with your point and I agree with uh
representative leas we we need to be
based on uh correct scientific decisions
and uh that's why uh we want uh to have
uh data on both sides on vacc in
efficacy and uh if you say it's not
relevant like but it's the same with
masks so if you read uh the hands outs
for mask sufficiency none of these
papers say New
Hampshire it doesn't say New Hampshire
response but it's relevant for us
because we want to our decisions to
based on uh correct policy regarding
masks Effectiveness or respirator
effective
so just the same way as uh this mask
review is relevant to our mission uh I
see this letter is also relevant to our
mission just on different
policy representative beler then
representative Merchant thank you madam
chair I just I would just respond to
some of the um the arguments that have
been made which I I understand I think
the perspective of um but I I would
suggest that within our our statement
for the for the mission of this
committee and the description and what
we've undertaken um there there is
nothing that I can see that would uh
remotely limit us um from being able to
look at policy and what policies were
adopted and why policies were adopted in
fact the charge of the legislature
according to the New Hampshire
Constitution is really twofold um the
first one being uh the purse strings we
we have the funding capacity of the
state and the second um being the
creation of public policy and uh of
course oversight as well um so I I don't
see any any um reason to
artificially uh limit the jurisdiction
of the of the house as is
constitutionally granted for policy
oversight
um in uh in in this particular manner um
and I and I believe I would note and I
I'll have to pull it up because I I I
believe it's um not specifically house
rules but it falls under the um Mason's
Manual of legislative um uh rules um
that
uh it's within the uh discretion and
jurisdiction or discretion and authority
of a committee chair um to make a
request on behalf of the committee um
just a request not a not a subpoena or
anything of that nature here but just a
request uh for information thank
you represent Merchant thank you madam
chair I'll make three points
one for us to go back and to
evaluate whatever needed to be done with
covid implies as a state we have the
resources to do it so unless this
legislative body wants to fund a major
major I mean major body with scientists
and so forth to re-evaluate what's going
on with the federal government I don't
think we have the resources to do it
number two if we do that's a complete
redundancy and it goes against taxpayer
dollars and spending them wisely number
two is going to be a mountain of data I
don't know about you folks I don't have
the expertise to evaluate that data
that's going to be in front of us and I
don't know where we're going to get the
resources unless again we're going to
fund those resources and somebody wants
to Pony up if we have the first strings
we have the authority back to legisl
body and ask for the hundreds of
thousands of dollars that we need to
make this thing work and number four as
far as the Constitutional I don't
disagree with representative beler we do
have a constitutional Authority and so
forth but what I'm going back to is the
law that we passed if we wanted to talk
about policy when we passed the law we
should have been included it in the
policy at the time when we passed the
RSA we did not we talk about the
response to it not the evaluation of the
resources that were going to be utilized
so that was the time to talk about what
we wanted to do as a committee and what
we wanted to do is a legislative body
with the oversight that was a time to
debate it on the floor and have that
discussion we did not we talked about
how we're going to respond to it so that
goes back to the policy and for those
reasons I cannot support this letter and
I would move this this committee before
it even sends out this letter it goes to
the house speaker for clarification for
the house
Speaker represent P off represent
like uh I appreciate concern for tax
space funds and I would agree if uh this
letter was demanding to create a new
system to track vaccine safety like vve
but this letter doesn't demand creating
of
vve it just asks
about data that as we know was produced
through vve so it's not about additional
expenditures from taxpayer uh money but
it's exactly the opposite it's about the
utilization of the systems that was
already funded by taxpayers and
taxpayers are entitled to those answers
funded representative
leus I'm going back to
the policy
part
um different states resp responded very
differently with the same federal
guidelines because different states
checked it out differently there were
Governors um who actually read all the
read the
studies um had meetings with for
instance the doctors who
said they use these different protocols
to great effect some of which we've
heard from
about um and having done that they went
against what the federal government was
saying and went based on what they
themselves were learning from other than
just the federal government like from
doctors who had great success and
changed their protocols and changed
their rules um and so I think it's
important that we think about in any
response in the future how we're going
to do that instead of just taking
one
person one person's recommendations in
the federal government but to actually
look at the big picture how are we going
to do that and how are we going to
evaluate because as we've seen
now some of that advice Not only was
wrong we are hearing in the news lately
where they're admitting that yeah they
kind of knew it was wrong um and so
um I don't know I think we need to be
thinking about how we are going to
evaluate what advice we're getting to
figure out what we're going to do in the
future representative
eil thank you I still even aside from
all of that policy operational issue I'm
looking at this request it's like again
I I respect what you did but it's
enormous I mean access to all
communication from any Personnel within
your agencies for the last four years I
mean that's enormous and all the data on
all these different programs I really I
I don't even know what we I don't I
don't know how long it would take to
comply with this request I don't know
how expensive it would be for the feds
to put together the response to this
request I'm not sure how we would ever
have the capability to review
all of the information um and we have
very limited I mean I certainly have
limited medical capacity to review it
I'm just even if you just set aside
whether you think it's right or wrong to
send this letter this request is just
unbelievably um Broad and and and I I
can't support it so it's almost noon I
think what we have to do is decide I
mean if you want to take a vote Vote or
or or whatever or if you want to take a
shot at refining the letter um but I I
can't support it as it is representative
Merchant thank you m chair um if we want
to as a committee and I'm following up
on represent
leas I don't disagree as far as the
issue of the policy but I think if you
want to include in the review in
saying how did we as a state review the
information
that's internal to us not so much the
validity of the data coming to us but
how do we internally look at data that
we receive and evaluate its merits
that's different than going back to the
federal government asking for the source
of data and doing unnown analysis but
looking at the process is saying what's
the process we have in the state to
evaluate this information to ensure that
we're doing the right thing and I think
that has merits to it and number two
when you start looking at the end result
and I keep going back to this to our
committee I use the number of deaths per
100,000 and I am proud to say that as a
state we were the second lowest in the
country the only one lower than us was
Hawaii because they could lock down the
island so when you start looking at the
use of the Poli the information there
are other states I don't disagree they
didn't follow the same logic that we had
here but you can see where the variance
and what it created so if you're looking
at the end result being deaths and
people survived which to me is
critical then I think we did a fa a good
job in using the information we had but
if you want to go back and say what's
the process we do internally because a
lot of ways that's to me is more key
than trying to get down all this
like I think part of this part of our
assignment is looking at not deaths but
other like we've seen in the education
field huge harms that were done based on
policies that were followed that were
now
finding uh the people who suggested
those policies actually knew they were
not effective and would not work and we
are seeing those harms and part of it is
not just deaths but what are the other
harms were there harms to businesses
were there harms how many people died
not from covid but from despair you know
the um suicide rate went way up what
could we what could we have done
differently to keep that from happening
um kids like two years behind
developmentally Etc could we have done
things differently what did we need to
look at and and um I think those are I
was I'm talking more of the
general because comments are made of the
general what we as a committee should be
doing not so much the specific
letter I was saying I was talking about
our general not so much the specific
some for us to be able to make
decisions based on what other
organizations did I think important for
us to understand how those organizations
work because you know that'll that'll
affect okay is this should we trust
everything coming out of here or should
we be asking questions um Etc from
different
organizations but I do agree that when
it comes to this that last sentence
further we would request access to all
community that that is just I agree
that's way overboard way overboard but
the the original stuff were really just
asking we had testimony
supposedly about this organization so do
we believe with that testimony do do we
search it a little farther and find out
can we get verification from that
organization I think that's a reasonable
thing for us to
do representative Evo um oh gosh now I
just looked at at representative
Merchant and completely lost my my train
of thought um but I thought you actually
no I know what it was you had a um I
really appreciate the discussion I I
think though you had a good point
representative Merchant when you said
maybe another way of looking at this is
not so much as trying to take a really
deep dive that that is going to be very
difficult for us to do um on what the
federal decisions were but maybe talk a
little bit more with the public health
people and understand that when these
policies come down do you exercise
independent judgment how how are those
policies that you're getting and The Dru
and the instructions that you're getting
how are they assessed and I I mean and I
wouldn't be surprised if they said this
was a pandemic we were in like you know
pandemic mode and we didn't have a lot
of time to sit back and assess
everything um but then we could say okay
well in a similar situation like this
what sort of um policies could we put in
place that would give some structure to
the kind of analysis that you might want
to do I mean that sort of thing but this
is an enormous um task uh to to dive
into it at this this level and maybe we
might even just want to wait until we
see the after action report from
Homeland Security and then uh take
action following
that representative
belch thank you madam chair just to
speak to a couple of the issues that
been brought up including the the the
bipartisan concern here that uh
accessing the communications records for
the anything um responsive to the other
questions asked here and I I just want
to point out that it's only been about
about two weeks um since nationally the
uh Federal Department of Health and
Human Services took the rather extreme
step of sanctioning to the point of
permanent
disqualification the organization's ecoh
Health Alliance and its uh proprietor uh
Peter daik who were involved in um
Corona virus gain of function
research they took these extreme steps
against this organization which direct
directly relates to pandemic response
and the whole issue we're looking at
they took this extreme step not based on
the information that they were provided
based on questions asked to this
organization but because they got a hold
of this organization's internal
Communications and found discrepancies
between what they were being told and
what was happening internally in the
organizations where they discovered
malfeasance and the purposeful
withholding of information that may have
been critical at an early point in this
pandemic and that's that's the reason I
I um I included that particular thing
I'm not looking for every bit of
communications from the entire agencies
during that period only those that are
responsive to the handful of questions
that are posed within this document um
it may be a substantial tranch of of
data I would be happy to parse it I
think if we lack the internal resources
I think that a um a sort of um what's it
called the socially networked review of
it could bring anything important to
light for us um and frankly I I think
without those docu without access to
internal Communications I I see almost
no point in even asking these questions
because we have to be able to verify the
veracity of them um by seeing what they
were talking about internally as you
know a contemporary to the decisions
being made um and I I would say given
that there is obviously
some uh debate over where the authority
lies for sending a letter like this I I
would recommend do we perhaps consult
with the parliamentarian to see just
what what his input is on it I I would
if I can Mr yes I would strongly
recommend that because if we're going to
send something to a federal government
and we don't per se even have the
authority to send a letter it's not only
going to fall flat when they receive it
it's going to make us look in a bad
light and if we don't have the
jurisdiction within our legislative body
and I like to have someone put that
forth and saying yes we do or we do not
because if we don't we shouldn't be
sending the letter at all that's the
first question the other one's going to
be when all this information comes back
if it ever comes back are we going to
get it back in time to evaluate it
before a report due by November 1st and
on top of that I want to say rest Bel I
want thank you for willing to dive into
a mountain of paperwork uh to do it but
I can tell you from my point of view I
don't have the expertise I'd like to
send it to my social network but a lot
of the people in my social network don't
have the expertise to really look at the
documents themselves and make that
evaluation so without having someone who
truly has your credentials to look at
that information coming back to us I'm
not sure what we can do with
it so I agree and I would never send out
a letter like this without checking with
the speaker's office first off just so
everyone understands
um the other thing is is
um the biggest question I have and I
would really really like an answer to Is
the vve
data I think after the what we heard
that hearing I have so many questions
and I want to know
they decided and we heard in testimony
and it was shown to us and I actually
have some of the slides that I have to
send off to the committee from that
presentation so I'll get those uh P
slides out to everyone um but why in the
middle of doing a
scientific protocol they change
Midstream to mimic another agency when
they're two separate agencies
to me that is the biggest question when
the data was reflecting something that
probably wasn't what they wanted based
on what we saw but I want to know
myself if it's you know I'm told that
it's factual but I want to verify it I
always like to verify what I
have Madam chair I would totally I think
that if we can narrow this down to that
one
issue okay then the scope of the
information coming back is going to be
minimal compared to the other mountain
of data and at that point in time based
upon that we can probably find some
resource internally within the state to
evaluate it but if this letter as
written is so broad the scope is Way
Beyond this committee but if you want to
narrow it down to strictly that one
issue and that one issue only and you
also go to the speaker's office
parliamentarian to be sure that we as a
committee and particular yourself as the
chair who signs off on it that you have
the authority to do that
I um would absolutely never send
anything out without the authority of
the speaker's office or the
parliamentarian um ever um but I
think that narrowing the scope of this
would May ensure not guarantee that we
may get data back over the summer in
time for the report um and I had like I
said I had so many more questions um
about the testing of this and the
decisions made by the different
departments um and this was of
particular concern to me because it
would
affect um basically it could affect how
every state handled things um
technically and representative crean
cran has a
question I guess um just with respect to
requesting V and there is data um that's
actually all like publicly available you
can just go online and get it so um I
don't think we need to necessarily
request those data um certainly just
want to mention that in interpreting
those data um it's really key to keep in
mind that these are all just reports
that people make
voluntarily um there's nothing to verify
that they're
accurate um certainly
not saying that this was a common thing
but I certainly saw you know on social
media people saying they shouldn't be
pushing vaccines we got to
flood these reports with you know
information about data so I think that
those might not be the most useful data
for us to look at when
considering side effects and efficacy as
opposed to you know information from
hospitals that that sort of thing um
and then finally just just um to this
idea of the control group receiving a
vaccine um at some point after the
vaccine was approved um my understanding
is that's like a pretty common thing
because when you're doing a clinical
trial if you see that there's evidence
of efficacy it becomes an ethical issue
to withhold um the effective treatment
from the control group so um I don't
think that's something that we should I
I think um
harping on that would reveal a lack of
understanding on our part and I would
not sign on to that so I understand
about the their's data where that's
voluntary a lot but the vsafe data was
only given to people that received the
actual vaccine it was a very
controlled uh group of I think it was
was it
10,000 I believe 40, whatever but and
the data was populated but it was only
for those that were vaccinated so it's
very
specific and um so that data was
specific and the other thing was how the
FDA and the CDC they had
protocols on what scientific method each
group was going to
do and one of the Midstream and I'm not
sure which agency was switched over to
the other one and disregarded everything
else that they had gotten that is of
concern because
that so yes Madam chair I think we're we
could go in this is saying when that
happened between the agencies and there
was a change I'd asked the question to
the people at the state level how did
that impact your assessment because I
think it's going to be how we responded
to the information that was provided to
us versus a source of the information
and I think that's more critical than
looking at going through mountains of
data is asking our state resources how
do we utilize information what's the
process how do we evaluate it and when
something gets switched from One agent
to another what did you do to me that
makes more sense than trying to go out
this it's a rabbit hole and I'd rather
look at it and saying I got the rabbit I
don't need to find the hole is talk to
the person at the point in time it's
Department of Health Human Services May
it's Ben Chen Dr Chen is what did you do
and why' you do it that to me has more
merriage to it than this whole letter
well this is only based on one person's
testimony as well that's all we
have representative
leus I think to even be able to do that
we have to understand what
information they had so we've found out
now due to all of the um requests that
he's made and everything that these
things happened but did we even know
that did they even let us know that they
changed their policies seems like that
would be something that's important for
us to to know because if we're not
getting information from these agencies
that I I can't hear
you I guess I'm my concern is going to
be as legislators it's not for us to
have that information is more for the
people who are we rely upon that we put
in positions that have that Authority is
how they use that information again it's
back to how the state responded by using
the information because I want to know
how the state responded and how they
evaluated the information they were
utilizing to me that's more critical
than this whole issue of the FDA and CDC
and so forth that's that's what I'm
trying to get to well what I'm saying
is if they're not getting the
information they should be getting they
may be responding perfectly to the
information they got but we have
this a lot of information that has come
out later that said these things were
happening that nobody knew about at the
time and so were our agencies
basing their response on incomplete
information and how do we in the future
try to make sure they getting complete
information I think it refers to
something called money Monday Morning
Quarterback representative Belcher thank
you madam chair I just wanted to make a
little bit of a correction because I
think there was a bit of a misstatement
regarding one of the questions that is
in here just to be clear this letter
does not ask did these uh vaccine
manufacturers immunize the control group
as a part during the study that's not
what this asks because that would be a
useless question because it last con it
lacks context rather here's what the
question actually
asks can you verify the vaccination of
the control group occurring despite
objections from either of your agencies
now that's important because we receive
specific testimony that the vaccination
occurred over the objections of federal
regulators and that would be an an
interesting point to know that might
help us understand the the overall
picture here a little bit um so it's
it's a totally different issue than did
they can vaccinate the control group
because of course they're always going
to eventually vaccinate the control
group if it's approved the key there is
did any of the agencies asked them not
to vaccinate the control group and did
they move forward with that over the
represent po
off I just I want to return to previous
topic so I don't know if we are done
with this
one uh just one second um right now
we're at an impass regarding the
letter I think that the first thing I'm
going to do is go to the speaker's
office and see if this is something that
we can send out as a
committee um
and once I get that then I guess the
next question is is do we refine the
letter do we how do we move forward um
whether if he says yes or he says no I
mean no is going to be pretty
straightforward uh and that will end the
discussion um so we'll just uh but if he
says yes then the next question is
is the drafting of the drafting of the
letter so won't be here
[Music]
um so I I'm I'm not exactly sure how to
move forward with that portion of it and
I've got multiple hands represent a Evel
represent beler represent a merchant
okay so all I can say is I've got to
leave at 12:30 but um
so one thing we could do in the meantime
is we could actually inquire of DHHS or
whomever and just say in the face of the
testimony that we receive that asserted
this um we'd be interested in you
developing you know an answer for us uh
you know whether you observe this
phenomenon whether this is just based on
the testimony that we happen to get I
mean you could ask them about this and
how they responded and that would get at
this
whole issue of of the response but the
other thing we can do is we can just
wait and see what this after Action
Report says and what is in there um but
I think it's going to be hard for us to
reach consensus on the letter over the
summer and the last thing I want to say
is there's nothing that stands in the
way of an individual representative
requesting information themselves
through the foia process which both
these agencies
have thank you I do think that we need
to definitely reach out to DHHS they I'm
Hope was hoping that once we get through
this section there's um some folks that
I'd like to have in in the fall I'd like
to have DHHS in again Dr Chan um some
people from special ed um even the
Department of Labor because I think um
dealing that um department has a lot to
do with um the Federal Emergency dollars
and how the Ripple effects are still
affecting us today with decisions that
have come down uh through that um so
leaving at that uh representative beler
then representative Merchant thank you
madam chair and um here's kind of how I
I'm envisioning this and you can tell me
if you think I'm correct um I fully am
supportive of of going of course
Consulting the parliamentarian seeing
what the procedure in place is for for
an item like this I see a sort of
decision tree coming either it's going
to be a uh we don't have the authority
which I I don't think is going to be the
answer but okay we're done number two um
we have the authority but it falls to a
vote of the house well that would mean
it's out for this year we have the
authority but it falls to a vote of the
committee uh which would have to wait
till the next time week reconvene which
will be in the fall which is probably
too late to submit this the last and
final which I see is probably the only
way to proceed on this and is what I am
pretty sure actually is the correct
parliamentary rule is that the Authority
for this lies with the chair um in which
case it would be on the discretion of of
Madam
chair if I may respond Madam chair I at
this time I don't think that would be
feasible simply because we're not
meeting again until fall can I make a
recommendation thank you madam chair I
don't know exactly legislative what you
can do I know when I was on the board uh
a Board of Pharmacy at the time when we
had something like this what the chair
could do was to draft something send it
to each one of us we could not resp to
all because it's 91a violation but we
could respond individually to the chair
saying we approve or disapprove so it's
like taking a vote um without going
through the process but it has to be
done in a way and it's is good talk to
the parliamentarian because
legislatively I don't know what the
rules are but on the board we would send
out the draft each board member could
respond yay or nay and at that point in
time they can move forward if I may
chair just to respond to that I am I can
just about guarantee that would uh that
would violate parliamentary procedure
because it would effectively represent a
remote vote um if if it does in fact
require a vote I don't I don't think
there's going to be any way to move
forward with this I think the only path
forward is if we do find it is at the
discretion of the chair in which case
it's just that simple and I and I would
be happy to work with uh Madam chair
to accept any revisions or or plug
anything else in that that would be
appropriate represent
black If instead of taking a vote yay or
nay what we do is communally
um make
suggestions for making it better you
could do that and then Madam chair would
decide whether or not to send it or not
that way it's still it's up to her which
she would have the authority for but she
would have the input from all of us the
the other was in the meantime if I can
ask the chair go back to represent
Able's um question I would recommend the
chair send a letter to the Department of
Health Human Services and saying what is
the process when you receive information
and you have possibly conflicting
information how what's the process how
do you decide how to move forward with
the policy based upon the information
that's provided to you A how do you
assess it B how do you utilize it to me
that's more appropriate with our own
state agency coming from the chair
asking that fundamental question to the
department thank you for that represent
Merchant I I think it's important um and
the question is is I wouldn't assume
that they receive conflicting
information they may not have um and
maybe the question is is how did you
assess the information um instead of
reading something into that
represent I mean basically you can pose
the question to them that we got
testimony from this person I mean we'll
have the slides or whatever and he
asserted x y and z um to your knowledge
was that the situation and if it was the
situation how did you respond you know
something like that I mean I think this
whole thing we're assessing obviously
but I also think it's just really
difficult because people were scrambling
you know trying to do their best
representative
leus I know we keep saying people were
scrambling but this was a two-year
response in the beginning I'm willing
to I I'm willing to excuse any mistakes
that were made in the beginning because
clearly there was a lot we didn't know
and everybody was doing their best and I
believe everybody was doing their best
but there were a lot of decisions that
got made along the road where we weren't
scrambling where there was time and so
those are the we need to look at that um
but the other thing is to ask them is
were they aware I mean did they know
this information because that's part of
what we want to see is where are we
getting complete information where is
the breakdown in communication now we
see this and it's one thing to say how
did you respond to this but they might
not have even gotten this information
and so that would be a question to ask
them is we received testimony that this
is what
happened did you were you aware of this
at all you know was this something that
even came across your plate for you to
even
consider
represent the letter sort of lays out
the some of the question questions right
but I mean unfortunately we're in a
situation now where we're not meeting
over the summer and that's just know I'm
not sure what we can do about that but
we can ask the question in the meantime
if we to right and I will speak with the
uh speaker um probably today if he's in
and
uh if and if not it'll be next week uh
but anyways uh to to get an answer on
this
um but I think it's important and to
represent of leus Point yes at first
everyone was scrambling nobody knew what
was going on but 6 months in there was a
lot of conflicting information coming
out and um and then as we heard uh in
testimony from uh The Honorable
representative gay um horable gay she
she um had some really good points to
make about um be because you know people
with different mindsets coming together
to Hash it out because to me that's what
makes the best policies okay because
you're taking in all points of view so I
think it's important that we understand
that we all come are coming from a
different uh perspective on this um
we've all we all experienced something
different during the
pandemic and it's it's individual for
everybody um so I think in light of that
I think sending something off to DHHS is
important but I will also consult the
speaker regarding the letter and I will
let the committee know what the speaker
says representative paaz off does have
something to
say Madame chair I I need to leave as
well I just want to say thank you for
chairing this and hopefully everyone has
a great summer and it's restful and
relaxing after the community conferences
we had so but thank you for what you're
doing yes thank you very much it's a
good conversation uh thank you all I
know that some of you are leaving uh so
but represent poov has uh you have the
floor yeah thank you Madame chair and
thank you representative Merchant for
share data on review of mask
Effectiveness uh I I need to make sure
for the record that that review also
showed that deaf people uh have uh
challenges when masks are used and that
people with certain medical conditions
you can see it in the summary they
require some exceptions and during the
pandemic we we knew that it was very
difficult and often impossible to get
necessary medical exception that review
also raised the question of mask H to
children and it's not in the summary uh
uh what was the finding uh second point
out of three points I need to make about
it uh is uh this review raised some
controversy around uh fully fitted patus
versus close close masks and uh you can
see it on the page five of the uh hand
out that uh there was a revision that
need to be made because uh there was
misunder understanding of what this
review uh did and they even used a
picture of a mask that according to that
review was not effective so they had to
change the picture used for that review
because uh
uh a misunderstanding of what that
review actually says and a certain point
to what representative Merchant uh uh
stressed that masks are creating social
cultural change even regardless
effective they are or not and I agree
with this point I just don't agree with
seeing it as necessarily positive things
so uh when representative Merchant says
that uh when everyone forced to wear
masks it means that virus is serious
yeah yeah yes it's true but it's
creating pressure it creating stress it
creating fear when there's a pressure we
see the situation when medical exe
exemptions that need to be uh granted
are not granted uh we we see that
patients have worse outcome and it's uh
pretty uh
established scientific knowledge that
stress
actually vers outcome during the illness
so if it's not necessary it can have ver
population outcome and finally it's uh
we have separation of state and religion
for reason we we shouldn't be just uh
based on beliefs we believe that it's a
deadly disease and we are all going to
die like if facts are contradicting it
we shouldn't be forcing people to wear
masks just to because it's our belief
that doesn't matches the fact and actual
uh death rate for example among children
uh so those are my point regardless uh
uh papers that were distributed thank
you I I thank you for sharing that
represent po off uh does anybody else
from the committee have any thing that
they wish say uh representative beler
thank you madam chair and I I would like
to thank representative paulol and I
would I would essentially second those
remarks in that I think um when the
state decides to make um certainly
mandates perhaps even recommendations
but certainly mandates that are of a
symbolic
nature in order to um in order to steer
people and any sort of particular
direction I believe that is
fundamentally a violation of the freedom
of conscience and it really gets it
Mighty close if not over the line of
violating the establishment of religion
clause of the First Amendment thank you
thank you represent Belcher does anyone
else have anything else they would like
to
add seeing none
um I hope everyone has a wonderful
summer
and uh I will see you all in the
fall uh so I will call this meeting